so first quick note you should have
absolutely used a ruler to draw this
thing up okay excuse me also a handy
thing it's not on this diagram but you
guys should go a little better that this
is a right angle triangle so we really
probably want to put that little square
in the corner to say yeah this is 90
degrees okay then I've got my
measurement on there
nine there's my units 40 and then this
is the side way trying to find out now
this side it has a name cuz it's special
what's this cycle it's the high point
it's very good you can think about a
couple ways it's the longest side it's
the longest side so that means that 9
and 40 this hypotenuse is gonna be
longer than that for sure so if you got
an answer and it's less than nine or 40
something is gone amiss okay so just
have a look at your answer to check that
up secondly it's the side it's opposite
the right angle all right there's two
different ways to think about the
hypotenuse will someone like to give me
a suggestion what should be the very
first line that I write down from this
triangle yeah Brennan okay yeah so I've
gone
remember what Pythagoras theorem is
which is the topic we're finishing off
today I've got the square off the two
shorter sides this squared B squared
should be equal to the square of the
longer side right so I could write down
a squared B squared C squared
but in this triangle I know what a B and
C are so I'm gonna write that down 9
squared plus 20 squared equals x squared
okay so that's what my first plan looks
like right if it's your second left
that's all good no problem now what's
the reason for this we're not just
plucking this out of thin air
it's like cuz I think so what's the
actual reason that I should attach on
the side of this should I say two words
Pythagoras's theorem
I thank you okay so here we go I've
stated something true and I've said why
it's true now what do I do
yes No okay so if I had say X bit on
this side and dice purposefully squared
on the right-hand side
that's a great question what do you guys
think is it okay to have it the other
way around
do we think it's okay I agree with you
but why like is that just random
sometimes you can sometimes your car why
should that be all right yeah what do
you think the only very good this is an
equal sign right
so both these things really we're saying
they're the same they are identical in
fact so absolutely we can do it either
way okay so now I can do some of these
numbers now nine square in the 40
squared you may have reached through
your calculator Fenella but let's see if
we can do it without no it's great I
think we know this one at st. what 40
squared that's gonna be a big number
1,600 1,600 is an easy way to work that
out you do the fourth 16 and that zero
looks like a 10 so 10 times 10 is a
hundred so 1,600 a dirt that works
that's equal to x square okay so I'm
just gonna whack that to get up now I
don't know about you but this number is
too big for me I don't know what the
spirit of what that season who anyone is
off the top of my head so I'm gonna
reach to my calculator and it's gonna
tell me there you go sir our length is
41 centimeters X is just a number right
if you're a doubt x equals 41
centimeters that's not too bad that's
okay but just think about it if I put
that back up here then it would be 41
centimeters centimeters because already
got some reason so to be like saying an
ATM machine or a PIN number which is a
bit redundant so you don't need to have
an extra centimeters there I'm just
gonna leave it as 41 okay
great okay let's have a girl at the
second one and let's do it a little bit
the car okay
let's creep me dry okay yeah this time
instead of writing out the steps because
I have there and you can see one two
three four lines or just every time we
exactly the same this time you've got
this different kind of Rachel because
I'm not trying to find the hypotenuse
anymore am i right
so my first equation is gonna be a
little bit different looking you're
trying to find isn't always there on its
own so what should I write instead yes
no okay great so I can see the same
relationship there excuse me
and I've got the same reason for
languages theory stating your reasons is
really important a computer can tell me
numbers but a human is what I need to
give you reasons okay all right now you
can crunch that through I've got a 36
data little Y squared doesn't want to
talk about eighteen point five squared
is who's got it already written down
there yeah
have you got the afterwards yes willing
to point to five thank you very much now
that looks like skin tat awkward isn't
it if I subtract 36 from both sides tell
me if I'm doing this right that looks
like 300 and 625 now that looks like
it's gonna be so all full messy number
looks like it's gonna be a sir doesn't
it yeah how would we know if it is or
not these are calculated just like you
did over here take the square root and
what do you find
sixteen seventeen point five so I'm
gonna write that as seven say my mom
okay sure
conveniently actually is kind of a
square it's not that bad okay so it's
not a certain there we go I'm done